>> Sean: JOINING US NOW THE
HOST OF LEVIN TV AND THE HOST
OF "LIFE, LIBERTY AND LEVIN"
ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
THIS WEEKEND, GOVERNOR PALIN
WILL BE ON YOUR SHOW.
I LIKED GOVERNOR PALIN.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM HER IN A
WHILE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WATCHING,
MARK.
SO THE BIG QUESTION NOW IS
WHAT THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
DO.
APPARENTLY THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS NEGOTIATED WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL OVER THE IDEA
THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD SPEAK
WITH ROBERT MUELLER.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF IS LIKE
I HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE.
I'D SPEAK WITH HIM.
IF THERE IS NO UNDERLYING
CRIME, IF COLLUSION IS NOT A
CRIME AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
THE RIGHT TO FIRE COMEY OR
ANYBODY ELSE AND EVEN COMEY
ADMITTED AS MUCH, THEN THE
QUESTION IS, YOU KNOW, IF THEY
WANT TO GET IN THE PRESIDENT'S
MINDSET, THOUGHTS CAN'T
REPRESENT A CRIME IN MY
OPINION.
YOU ARE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
EXPERT.
WOULD YOU ALLOW IF THE
PRESIDENT WAS YOUR CLIENT,
WOULD YOU ALLOW HIM TO SPEAK
TO ROBERT MULER?
>> NO.
LET ME TELL YOU, I WOULDN'T
ALLOW HIM TO SPEAK FOR HIS
SAKE OR THE SAKE OF THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS A ROGUE PROSECUTOR WHO
IS INVESTIGATING NOTHING.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
HE IS INVESTIGATING NOTHING.
THERE IS NO UNDERLYING CRIME.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD NOT PROVIDE BASIS FOR
THE APPOINTMENT.
DIDN'T SAY THE CRIMINAL
STATUTES TO INVESTIGATE.
THERE AREN'T ANY.
I WANT TO MAKE A POINT I DON'T
BELIEVE ANYBODY ELSE HAS MADE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
PRESIDENT, THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS AND THE NATION.
THE OFFICIAL POSITION OF THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE UNDER DEMOCRAT
ADMINISTRATION WAS SET OUT BY
THE OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN
TWO MEMORANDA.
IT SAYS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CANNOT BE
INDICTED WHILE HE IS IN
OFFICE.
CANNOT BE INDICTED WHILE IN
SO HE CAN'T BE A CRIMINAL
TARGET.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES CAN'T BE A CRIMINAL
TARGET BECAUSE HE CANNOT BE
THAT IS THE OFFICIAL POSITION
OF MR. MUELLER'S BOSSES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THAT IS NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, I KEEP HEARING BUT
WHAT IF HE IS SUBPOENAED TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE GRAND JURY?
WELL, THEN YOU GO TO THE
FEDERAL JUDGE AND YOU SAY TO
THE FEDERAL JUDGE YOUR HONOR,
MY CLIENT CAN'T BE INDICTED.
THAT IS THE POSITION OF HIS
BOSSES SO WHY IS HE GOING IN
FRONT OF A FEDERAL GRAND JURY?
WE NEED HIM AS A WITNESS.
A WITNESS TO WHAT?
WHAT CRIMINAL STATUTE, WHAT
CRIMINAL VIOLATION DO YOU
THINK HE WAS A WITNESS TO THAT
HE NEEDS TO TESTIFY TO?
"WELL, WE THINK HE MAY HAVE
COMMITTED OBSTRUCTION.
EVEN THOUGH WE MAY NOT TRY
HIM --"
EXCUSE ME, MR. MUELLER.
THIS IS A CRIMINAL GRAND JURY.
THIS ISN'T DONE SO YOU CAN
ISSUE YOUR REPORT.
THERE ARE MANY CONSTITUTIONAL
OBSTACLES OF COURSE TO THIS
ARGUMENT THAT THE PRESIDENT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
FIRING A SUB BOARD NANT IS
OBSTRUCT -- SUBORDINATE IS
OBSTRUCTING OF JUSTICE?
THEN WHEN MUELLER FIRED STRZOK
THAT'S OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
TOO.
WHEN I WATCH PEOPLE COME ON TV
AND SAY HE CAN BE SUBPOENAED.
ANYBODY CAN BE SUBPOENAED.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU DAMN WELL HAVE A STRONG
REASON FOR TRYING TO DRAG HIM
IN FRONT OF A GRAND JURY,
NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, A FEDERAL JUDGE IS
NOT GOING TO JUST ACCEPT THAT
KIND OF A SPECTACLE AND
MR. MUELLER KNOWS IS.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE A DEAL.
YOU ARE GOING TO DRAG A
PRESIDENT DEALING WITH ISSUES
ALL OVER THE WORLD, DEALING
WITH CHINA, RUSSIA, NORTH
KOREA, IRAN AND BRING HIM IN
FRONT OF A GRAND JURY?
A JUDGE WILL NOT WANT THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
THAT IS WHY MR. MUELLER IS
TRYING TO NEGOTIATE SOME BASIS
TO INTERVIEW MR. TRUMP.
BUT IF I WERE MR. TRUMP I'D
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG,
THAT'S WHY I'M NOT TALKING TO
YOU.
NUMBER ONE.
I'LL PROTECT THE OFFICE FOR
THE DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICANS
ELECTED TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, NUMBER TWO.
YOU HAVE CRIMES THAT YOU WANT
TO PROSECUTE?
GO FOR IT, BABY.
BUT I DIDN'T COMMIT A CRIME.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE INDICTED.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE DRAGGED IN
FRONT OF A FEDERAL GRAND JURY
AND THAT IS THAT.
THAT IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD SAY.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK THE NEXT
QUESTION BECAUSE THIS IS KEY.
THERE HAVE BEEN VERY FEW OF US
THAT HAVE DONE A DEEP DIVE
INTO THIS CORRUPT TEAM THAT
ROBERT MUELLER PUT TOGETHER.
EVERYONE WILL SAY HE IS BEYOND